all right guys we're gonna get started
sorry for being late
so I have up here Elizabeth
irons is a dr. elizabeth iron sure you
are professor Elizabeth irons so
Elizabeth is a cancer biologist by
training you got your PhD in cancer
biology from University of London and
you did your postdoc and then became an
assistant professor which are still at
at University of Miami School of
Medicine got this correct cause so in
2011 she started science exchange then
called the bench which was an online
marketplace for outsourcing science
experiments and she was part of the Y
Combinator summer 2011 batch and
thinking might have been like the very
first biotech e-type company in YC right
that's where we stood it we started with
you and she's also the chairman of
reformer therapeutics which just went
through YC as well last batch she's also
a part-time partner at YC which means in
her free time she helps all our biotech
companies which this point is like
hundreds I don't know what the exact
number is but hundreds of biotech
companies so today I want to spend time
talking about two things in particular
one is running a marketplace company
since that's what science exchange is
and two is getting your perspective as
someone who's now advised hundreds of
biotech companies what you think about
what's going on the space and I'm in
particular because I think there's a
there's an increase in slope of by of
scientists coming in to the field so
that'd be cool to talk about so to get
started you're like I said you're a
cancer biologist by training you were I
believe doing breast cancer research
right after college I guess why how did
you even I mean you're in kind of going
to down the academic route like why how
did you even come up on startups where
did that idea even come come from yeah
yeah it was kind of random especially to
start a technology company like science
exchange rather than a biotech so I was
actually so I guess taking my
combinators advice without knowing about
Y Combinator's advice to solve your own
problem so I
was looking at the way that scientific
research was evolving and I was becoming
much more specialized much more
multidisciplinary hit deformities
collaborations with other labs in order
to access you know all of the latest
technologies and I experienced that
myself and realized that it was
incredibly inefficient and so that
process of how you find somebody to work
with how you evaluate the quality of
their ability to do that specialized
work and then even just the
infrastructure to actually work with
them so in in biotech in and scientific
research the actual ownership of the
scientific results is very important and
so just figuring out who is actually the
owner of those results who has the
intellectual property publication rights
all of those things is it's very
difficult and so I was talking about
this with my co-founder and we looked at
other examples of industries they'd
solved a similar problem so we're
looking at Oh deerskin Elance at the
time which have now become up work but
that was really an example of you could
solve this with a marketplace of experts
and that was the basis of science
exchange and it's never really kind of
evolved much more beyond that in terms
of the fundamental goal of what the
company wants to achieve can you dive a
little bit deeper there so before if I
wanted to do some research and run an
experiment basically what it sounds like
is this big disorganized process if I
need ten different things super
fragmented where this stuff is you I
guess I did give an example of related
to the research you were doing on how it
was so disorganized and then how science
exchange now collapses all that into one
place yeah definitely super disorganized
lots of fragmentation both in terms of
who you work with but also how you find
the information and in some cases the
information is actually not really
available so at the time when I was
working as a breast cancer researcher I
was running multiple different types of
experiments and one example was
microarray analysis which is definitely
showing my time away from the lab
because that's a very old-school
technique now but
but at the time it was you know what we
used to analyse gene expression
profiling and we just didn't have the
types of arrays that I wanted to use and
so I was trying to use Google and asking
my friends and asking my old lab can we
use your infrastructure and it was just
incredibly inefficient also actually the
the inefficiency drives a lot of
inefficiency and pricing in the market
so that was something that was a big a
big learning point for me at that time
point was you could actually create a
company that had margin in that space
because the market was so inefficient
due to the lack of information so for
example I was seeing literally ten times
price differences for an equivalent
experiment because people really just
didn't have access to what should it
actually cost and we see that still on
science exchange today is that when
people go and look for multiple options
and they actually don't have the
barriers of being able to work with them
they see very frequently price
differences that are quite extraordinary
for the same results that could be
generated got it so just to take one
step back
like when you were an academic I don't
know if that's a bad word but you know
when you're an academic maybe some
people like was that a tough choice to
just make that switch because I mean you
spent so many years studying for this
one thing and then you just are starting
essentially what is a tech company that
is not you know solving that one thing
that you suspend you open till that
point your entire life going after yeah
and actually at the time I didn't really
have a lot of role models to sort of
look to either so I was in Miami which
was not a very startup place and now
it's actually it's interesting to see
the evolution not just in the biotech
world but just generally in the startup
ecosystem and all of the infrastructure
that's been created like I think
University of Miami even has now an
incubator associated with the school of
mids and it helps people kind of create
companies I remember at the time having
this idea for a company and I
actually asked the university because I
was a little bit worried if I have this
idea while I'm still working there will
they try to get some ownership stake out
from the idea because actually when you
work in academia the the results you
generate don't belong to you so I think
that's kind of a common misperception
that you know universities actually own
your work so it's often a challenge to
spend those results out of the
university so it's kind of worried well
if I have this idea will will they own
it and so I went and talked to the tech
transfer office and they were just like
whatever I think go do whatever you want
and it was it was kind of interesting
and they didn't really have any guidance
on how to do that but coincidentally I
read about Y Combinator in Wired
magazine so there was actually a Wired
magazine interview all those years ago
about Y Combinator and that was where I
first learned about it and I was like
wow they're sounds super cool why don't
we just like apply for it and we were
total outsiders we didn't know anybody
at Y Combinator we didn't know anybody
that had gone through Y Combinator and
we just applied with this idea and
before it should enough to get in so you
talked oh you talked a little bit about
tech transfer I mean I do think that a
lot of people like me who are thinking
about starting a start-up do you think
that is a huge issue and in some sense
there are from some universities we've
have to work with what some of our
startups it is a huge issue what's your
do you have any advice for them on how
to navigate that process like should
that be the barrier in your mind yeah I
do think it is an issue if particularly
for scientific status because if you're
trying to spend our actual research that
was done already and I think people
often ask me like what's a good time to
join Y Combinator if you're creating a
science startup and actually I do think
a good time to join us once you've
already generated a lot of the R&D from
grant funded work because you don't want
to spend years and all of this money
trying to you know pursue a research
hypothesis you really want to be in the
development phase and so I think that
gets very difficult with a lot of the
universities I think some of them are
trying to be more
sort of found a friendly and create ways
to more readily license the results that
were generated but it's still you know
it's still a significant obstacle how do
you see that academics is a trend
they're moving more into startups or
what do you see or maybe we just get a
the bubble of you here in in San
Francisco but I mean that's our only the
thing I see anecdotally but is that do
you think that's a growing trend overall
yeah I think people are more willing to
just create companies I think generally
like think that's sort of a macro trend
way beyond Sciences you know really just
entrepreneurship has become this viable
career path and people are like oh yeah
I could be I could create a company and
it's just become a lot easier like the
infrastructure that's being created
through you know Y Combinator but also
through things like stripe and things
like AWS has made it so much easier for
people to create companies and I think
in the science space we're starting to
see that so obviously Sciences changes
you know one way to do that but there's
some really interesting other evolutions
like lab central and other lab space qb3
that provide you know lab space by the
bench that's very cost effective and you
can just rent you know one bench per
month and be able to get started really
cost-effectively so those things are
lowering the barriers to entry and so I
think academics what I would like to see
more of is how can we allow you know the
true I would say the analogy to what
we've seen in the in the engineering
world the software engineering world is
that the actual developers the software
developers become the entrepreneurs and
they maintain that and really build this
company around them I think that's still
very difficult for scientists
particularly PhD and postdoc scientists
so they actually make the discoveries in
these labs so the other ones doing the
work a lot of the time for them to
actually be the ones to be the founder
of the company is pretty challenging and
usually what you'll see is a
well-established famous PI's
principal investigator kind of being a
co-founder of that company just to give
it legitimacy and then that usually
allows people to bring in funding but
you know I think that's also kind of sad
like why do why do we have to have these
sort of figure heads who own large
stakes of these companies in order for
them to get off the ground and get
started and I want to see that change
you that's something we as you know talk
a lot about to people who when they
apply and then we see that kind of
structure and then you try to go help
them fix it essentially don't wanna lose
too much of your company too soon
all right so science exchange so you
already described you know what problem
you're trying to solve and then you've
decided at this point in 2011 to start
the startup how did you get your first
users and you have two sides in the
marketplace so it's doubly hard for you
how did you approach both sides yeah I
think marketplaces are really
challenging because you don't control
really the success of the business so
you don't I mean you do but you don't
have you're not just kind of building
something and selling it you have to
then make sure you have the things to
sell on the other side so it is really
challenging I think when we first
started we we were very MVP like in our
approach so I think in the first version
of Sciences change which as you
mentioned was actually called the bench
which was renamed during Y Combinator
thanks to programs very good advice
about our poor naming choice so you know
we we kind of threw up this website and
it was let you like put your what you
need on this website and then other
people will see it and they will give
you you know options which is even at
the time as a scientist I was like I
wouldn't use this make it seem like you
know very quick to get something up and
see who would test it out but it was
obvious right from the start they would
actually have to create you know a true
marketplace and have supply that was
visible and and actually even even more
so with Sciences change what we had to
do is create a curated marketplace that
operates in the b2b sector so what we
had to do is build QA so Quality
Assurance we had
actually qualifying contract every
provider that's available through the
marketplace and then surface all of the
results so that when somebody comes to
the marketplace they can literally find
what they need and they can give them
the information that's required for them
to be able to quote accurately because
they already know there's
confidentiality agreements in place and
and then they actually also had to
manage those projects because these
aren't just put it in your cart and
check out you have to actually manage a
project with somebody who works in
another part of the world from you and
so all this all this had to be built
into the software so that was many
iterations of learning about where we're
really as the value that comes from what
we are providing and I think
marketplaces have evolved a lot from you
know being predominantly consumer
focused there's a lot of interesting b2b
examples that are emerging in size
exchange obviously you know sits very
firmly in that category and well always
more difficult supply or demand
definitely demand so supply for us is it
was pretty straightforward in the sense
that you know providers are looking for
work and they providers of these
services they is a very fast growing
industry so also highly fragmented and
they actually also suffer the same
challenges that the demand size has so
for them if they want to sell one of
their projects they actually have to go
on contract with you know each client
they work with which can take several
months and they have to go through
Quality Assurance and gets it up and so
for them if they are on science exchange
now all of a sudden every one of our
clients can work with them instantly so
that's you know that's a huge value
proposition it took us a lot longer to
convince the large players in the market
so the large CRO is that this would be
something that they should be part of
but actually we have been able to do
that as well so I think one of the
important lessons that we learned
quickly was for this to be a really
effective solution it had to be the
platform that was used for everything at
the companies that were using it so not
just one-off come and shop on the
marketplace but actually use
a system for managing all of the
projects that are going on with the
external partners and in order to do
that you truly do have to have all of
the major players that they want to work
with on the platform and I've seen other
companies who have b2b marketplaces
struggle a little bit where they haven't
had the large established players on the
supply side and without that I think
it's very difficult to to have an
enterprise partnership that uses a
platform do you remember the very first
on the demand side the very first
customer what were they yeah I remember
actually so Alphaeus customers were
totally my friends who were who were
scientists who I would tell you if you
have experiments you're running you have
to try out science exchange and and they
actually you know was great user
feedback because for them it did turn
out to be you know it's really high
touch very you know very concierge
service so they found great options that
were really cost-effective so it wasn't
like you know they just used it because
we made them but I think they they
taught us you know enormous amount but I
also remember the first customer that if
it was just you know not related to us
like just came on to the platform and
used it and that was pretty exciting
we're actually in Italy on it my
brother's waiting and I was like oh my
god somebody who's that website yay stop
the wedding I need to check this out
only you know what was the experiment
they were trying to run do you remember
it was microarray as well like this was
popular at that time
oh so we talked a lot about that sort of
school product market fit for you what
was that like when did you know you had
that and how did you define it in what
metrics were you looking at yeah for us
I think we defined product market fit
when we've had our first large
pharmaceutical client actually use the
platform for whole sectors of their
business so for us that was am jian and
they used they launched science exchange
for all of their discovery research
which was a really big deal for us at
the time and
and we sort of realized oh we actually
have something that you know they do a
lot of steps manually at the moment and
this part this product actually
automates you know automates providing
all the information about who they
should work with who who is you know all
of these new options for new types of
technologies that they might be just
exploring and then even actually their
business and business intelligence
around you know looking at spend and
supplier performance so those things
those things took us a while to kind of
figure out where the core value props
were but you know you're onto something
when a big company who spent many years
and money trying to build the problem it
solve that problem internally has all of
a sudden just shifted to your product
and it's starting to pay you for that
that's a big thing not just in biotech
what in general for yeah I think yeah if
I mean much more so I think in software
there's it's really interesting because
people always ask me today like who are
your main competitors and you know how
do you kind of think about competitive
differentiation and all that and still
to me like our main competitor is status
quo so that people still sit up these
you know really crazy SharePoint
processes to manage their external
vendors and I always go in there I'm
like this is horrible like why are you
doing this and and you know big
companies they just love SharePoint
they're like oh yeah my SharePoint site
I have created all of these like really
Byzantine processes which only apply to
like five vendors I work with and
everyone else has to go through some
other crazy process and I'm like okay
but you can just transition all of that
onto this platform and you know it's
always this interesting kind of battle
of who set up that process because
trying to convince them that you know
the software automates all that hard
work is often actually one of our
biggest challenges so one of the things
I really love that you're doing and
announced a long time ago it was the
reproducibility initiative so the idea
that it seems obvious to do which is you
know if you run an experiment and you
publish results someone else should be
able to reproduce it to validate
that it's being done it's it so can you
talk a little bit about why you're doing
that what you're doing and why has this
never been done is it just been a money
problem or is it something that only
science exchange actually can do because
you have the process in place yeah the
reproducibility initiative is I still
think it's a really cool project it's
still very controversial even years
later Lee oh yeah I said come to my god
still so controversial it's
controversial because of a lot of
reasons I think the main reason is that
people are not sure of the value of it
which i think is legitimate like I think
there's still a question of how
efficient is it to replicate experiments
and that's that was actually you know
when you say is that science exchange
was the only way we could do it like elf
our hypothesis was that yeah having a
network where people already had all of
the you know write essays or the right
infrastructure or the right animal model
would be the only way that was actually
practically possible to do it
previously obviously people didn't have
that they had that same challenge of oh
I have to go find somebody who has that
same animal model or has that same
instrument and then I have to convince
them and contract them and all that kind
of stuff so yeah the reproducibility
initiative actually is kind of science
exchanges part of our mission to improve
the quality and efficiency of scientific
research and that that project is quite
broad so it covers both like things like
antibody validation which we've done a
lot of Surrey agent validation things
like reanalysis of Epidemiology results
so we worked with the Gates Foundation
to do that and then the projects that
we're most well-known for which is
actually replicating published results
and we do that both for the
pharmaceutical industry which is a way
easier and way less controversial
because they just come and say hey I'm
interested in this result and then we
quickly find you know a facility that
can replicate the key results and
provide this back to them however the
the cancer biology reproducibility
project and the prostate cancer
foundation project are the two ones that
people have followed the most which is
public
applications where we've actually
published the replication studies and
that's controversial because people
don't generally do this so I think it's
it goes against the cultural norm of of
really not publishing replication
studies I also think people are really
afraid and they sort of mix up failed
replication with things like fraud so
people are really afraid that if the
result is is found to be non
reproducible that that will have a
negative impact on their career which
which i think is you know probably true
but it shouldn't be so the reality is
that the results that have been
generated show that most published
results are not reproducible so if
that's true then we should try to
understand that and study it which is my
opinion as a scientist like we should
study the science behind why is this the
case rather than try to go after
individual people and say like oh your
science is horrible because clearly
that's not the case clearly it's that
most things are not reproducible when
they publish because of a variety of
complex factors of which we've started
to unpacked but I think there's still a
lot of work to do what are like the one
are the top two complex factors so I
think the main reason like that I've
seen things and not reproducible is the
quality of SA validation so it's really
interesting when you go and talk to
pharmaceutical companies because they
also transfer experiments so they
replicate experiments in the sense that
they'll see it something up at their
facility and then they'll outsource to a
CRO to run their si for them over and
over again and they're they call it tech
transfer or si transfer and that process
is incredibly efficient they can do this
very easily and it's got a high
probability of working and so when you
look at that I didn't think it's much
different than if you take a published
result and you try and rerun that si in
another lab but the main difference is
that when you work in a pharmaceutical
company you have SOPs you
of everything documented you look at sa
variability you look at positive and
negative controls there's just a lot
more actual validation of the type the
actual experimental essay that's used
before it's transferred and that's very
different than in academia so in
academia you tend to take oh yeah I've
got this animal model in my lab or I've
got this you know cell line in my lab
I'm just going to run this experiment
and hopefully you include a positive and
negative control but maybe not and you
also don't look at things like
variability of the sa reproducibility of
the sa and I think a lot of what we see
in publish results is likely to be noise
rather than true experimental effects
and so until we kind of understand that
more we will have an issue with
reproducing those results that's sort of
scary you're saving the world so save us
from this problem so going back to
science exchange what is the biggest
challenge as a CEO of a marketplace
company that you have today and how is
that how is that has that challenge
morphed over time like what was the
biggest challenge when you just started
- what is the biggest challenge today oh
yeah I'm sure like so many challenges
along the way when we first started
science exchange the biggest challenge
was can we get anybody to use it you
know that was kind of the first
challenge in the end can we can we build
something we are the very conservative
pharmaceutical industry will use it and
that was important for us because when
you look at spend break down the market
is you know predominantly for outsourced
research focused in the pharmaceutical
industry so so that they control over a
hundred billion dollars of spins per
year and so if we can if we couldn't get
them to use the platform we would have a
lot of issue with really creating a
truly large company today I think our
biggest issues are more around scaling
so how do we we're still only eighty
five people we've we've just signed a
couple of extremely large partners
and so we are really trying to execute
against some pretty tight deadlines with
staff that are focused on you know just
one of these large integrations and so
trying to kind of make sure that we
don't take on too much while also
realizing there's enormous opportunity
so we don't want to sort of overlook
that so I think just staying focused
executing on the right things and being
really disciplined about that which is
always really hard when you have when
you have multiple opportunities that you
can go after I think that discipline is
incredibly important yeah focus is
really hard especially as you get more
employees and you get more funding and
stuff like that so I want to switch
gears a little bit and talk about
biotech in startups as we talked about
earlier there has been this implosion of
biotech startups recently especially in
Silicon Valley
why do you why do you think that is
where are the causes for this
yeah the biotech industry is so
interesting right now and it's actually
amazing I love it's not just here in
Silicon Valley it's everywhere so the UK
Cambridge San Diego you know everywhere
there's like lots and lots of biotech
startups and and I think it's it's a
really cool time for that sector of the
industry it's I think driven by a couple
of things one capital so access to
capital is you know never as
unprecedented and the amount of capital
that's going into biotech is definitely
unprecedented there's also there's also
you know a sort of interesting evolution
and in terms of where biology is in
terms of the actual therapeutic
modalities that are available so I'm not
sure that people sort of who outside the
industry may not kind of recognize this
as a real turning point for biotech so
up until very recently there was really
only small molecule inhibitors and then
you know more in then after that there
was Genentech and mg and so there was
actual biologic so antibodies and
proteins but just in the last year we
had gene therapies approved we had cell
based therapy
approved we had our nai approved is
actual marketable products for the first
time so all of a sudden you have this
huge window opened up for you and the
different types of approaches you can
take that are viable to create a
commercial product so I think the
science is caught up to a point where
there's just some phenomenal
opportunities to tackle diseases in a
way that was not possible previously
interesting sort of like Moore's Law and
biotech yes really it's a really really
exciting time and there's also I think a
convergence on you know really a
critical mass of people looking at okay
I have this experience in the
pharmaceutical industry I'm going to go
into the biotech industry so again like
just so many people with really great
scientific experience with true
experience of bringing not from academia
actually in industry bringing drugs to
market and now going into biotech and
they're taking that risk and founding
companies and being early employees and
these like five person companies and I
never had seen that previously I think
that's a new phenomenon as well so you
just in this cool intersection of youth
built the software company marketplace
also a company and that intersects with
biotech and then on the same at the same
you have the perspective of advising
lots of more true I guess biotech
companies what do you what's the
difference between biotech and software
it's so different in terms of running
with the startup itself yeah it's really
different and I think in some ways you
know or let me let me rephrase the
question how is it the same as are there
any similarities I think it's the same
in terms of people and focus funding all
of those things that kind of same so
like trying to find the right people and
retain them building a good culture all
of those things actually I think YC is
really being able to do a great job of
having companies across different
sectors because of that focus on really
learning from successful entrepreneurs
so big lessons about creating a company
and not so much about the very you know
my new tactical details bio takes a
different
because you can't really change the
outcome of the science like the science
is the science so either it works or it
doesn't work and that's very different
than software where you can actually you
know pivot around and keep developing
your product and keep getting part of
market fit with with science is about
key milestones that demonstrate you know
real inflection points in terms of
mitigating the risk of the drug working
so actually having like different
different stages along the development
path where you know you've avenged got
to a point where you demonstrate in a
clinical trial that your drug is
effective at you know treating the
disease that you're trying to treat what
does an MVP mean in biotech yeah I think
MVP and biotech is as I don't even I
don't know if there is any MVP so you
know for a biotech company that's in the
therapeutic space you know really you're
not going to have any commercial revenue
until you have an approved product that
is sold on the market which actually
most biotechs never have so most bio
ticks go through you know process of
developing new therapies and they they
do partnerships with large companies
that fund you know the expensive
clinical development of those products
and so that's really we are a lot of
them end up kind of exiting so they
either acquired or they know sell or
partner that product in early clinical
development we're starting to see which
I think is really cool some biotech
companies actually commercialize their
own products now and that that was
something that didn't happen for quite a
long time so just recently there's
several companies that are actually you
know selling their product themselves so
building their own sales force and
distribute distribution channels and
those those challenges are really
interesting mostly those companies are
going after rare diseases where you can
you know go after key opinion leaders
and have a really efficient sales
channel but still it's still really
exciting to see them do that
that's great well let me actually double
down double-click on that point you made
so there's essentially what you're
saying is that I can bring my product to
market without getting acquired which
used to be the case at that specific
juncture what is what has changed that
is allowed that's happened yeah that's a
good question I think capital so access
to capital are really important that the
companies can actually access enough
capital to get all the way through to
approval I also think the FDA has done
some really interesting work trying to
come up with reasonable clinical
development strategies for particularly
rare diseases where companies can
actually get registration with a fairly
small trial so that makes it actually
feasible for a small company to be able
to do that and then in terms of
distribution I do think that strategy of
just building really strong patient
advocacy networks working with the key
opinion leaders in the community through
the hospitals that these patients are
treated at provides a way to distribute
that in the past I think if it's a
blockbuster indication it becomes very
challenging that you have to build a
huge sales force you have to go and kind
of sell this drug with you know sort of
old-school pharmaceutical sales reps
it's not it's not easy to do that I also
see this proliferation of startups maybe
actually since vein of signs exchange
where you're helping try to speed up
like experiments you're helping speed up
trials you're helping speed up getting
through the FDA process and so that may
be helping a little bit as well yeah
definitely like we've we've funded some
really interesting companies in this
space that kind of put in place for
example regulatory infrastructure for
the FDA so the expertise is out there
and people are starting to productize
that in a way that maybe wasn't
available previously so people would
have to go and hire you know regulatory
consultant that would be very expensive
you know literally like more than
hundred thousand dollars to come up with
come up with your FDA's
and now there are companies that you can
actually go and and work with them to
provide the the productized vision of
that process so enzyme is you know the
company that that Y Combinator funded
what you think is super interesting and
all of these are just enabling
technologies that will hopefully provide
the infrastructure similar to what we've
seen in the selfie space so you know
like we said before advised and you've
mentored hundreds of biotech founders at
this point what are some of the common
mistakes you've seen biotech founders
make and what are the ones that you
should you just need like what do you
avoid at all costs because it's a
detrimental yeah I mean I think like our
bio tech founders first of all are
really amazing because they are often
those people who have taken that risk
and have kind of stepped out of academia
or other very established careers and
see it I'm going to go do the startup
and there isn't really that many you
know role models for me to follow or
like success stories for me to follow so
I think they're they themselves are
incredibly impressive and often I do
offer sales with them and I'm like I'm
just learning from them like it's
actually really really cool but I think
you know one mistake I have seen people
make is just in it's it's I think all
startup founders kind of do this is like
not doing the killer experiment like not
actually just cutting to the chase and
saying okay
these are just the minimal things I need
to do to truly like answer the question
and you almost don't want to do it
because if it doesn't work the company's
kind of did and I sort of a lot of the
time push our companies a little bit I'm
like but why haven't you done that
experiment like that experiment would
tell you you know today if this is going
to work or not and I think it's just
it's hard when it's your own company to
kind of do that but the sooner you do it
the more the sooner you have enough
money to kind of work on something else
because like we talked about with
science if you can't get the actual
science to work you you know really are
in a difficult position so say you're a
scientist or you're not
who's looking to get into startups I
think a lot of people still think maybe
you do you need some kind of business
co-founder let's help me do XY and Z do
you what do you think about that in you
know should that be a goal no I don't
think that it should be a goal I think I
actually do have a business co-founder I
think it would probably be mad that I
say that but and he's great and I
literally couldn't have felt sizes
change without him but but not because
of his business background right like
because he's a great co-founder because
he's like hustles and figures stuff out
and we work well together I think
business so much of it is just common
sense like you I used to get so you know
consumed that I didn't have this finance
background I didn't know how to read
like all of the income statements and
all that and then I realized after a
while okay I'm just gonna sit down with
my business co-founder and he's gonna
teach me and so he taught me and then I
was like oh it's so obvious like it's
not it's definitely not rocket science
so I think I think that the business
side you know you really as a CEO and
when you grow the company one of the key
skills is actually recognizing the areas
that you're good at and better and what
where you should be investing and
bringing in top talent and so for us we
we recently actually hired a CFO so a
year ago we hired a CFO and that's been
I think good for the company but also
good from a perception perspective so as
the company reaches a growth a growth
stage actually having that sort of
legitimate CFO person does help you but
from like a starting out I mean starting
out you should just find people who
really want to solve the same problem as
you and really care about it and also
who you really like working with because
that's by far the most important thing
on the flip side if you're not if you're
not a scientist and let's say you're a
programmer but you're interested in
getting into biotech what what should
you do like should I go back to school
get my PhD like what's the what's a
potential path for me
there's a good question you know part of
me thinks like you should go back to
school like I think there is this
there's a lot of interest from Silicon
Valley in biotech like people are super
interested in just like even just
hacking themselves like this whole kind
of movement around like you know really
personalized like understanding all of
your own biology I think it's really
cool and I by the way do think that the
future of biotech and we are I always
think about for reformer and and the
work that we are doing is I believe that
the future will definitely involve a
strong component of user pays so I think
the products that are developed will
have to be in indications that the
patients are actually willing to pay for
and there's a lot of research at the
moment that's in areas which you know I
think are potentially problematic
because they're sort of diseases where
people are not really that sick or they
don't really feel sick and so getting
them to adhere to those medications very
very challenging in contrast like things
like migraine drugs actually amgen's
migraine drug has outperformed its
predictions in the market by ten times
and I think that's because people
genuinely go to the doctor because they
debilitated by migraines and they will
pay for those drugs so so I think trying
to you know think about ways that you
can focus on on users is good so anyway
to go back to three strings it got so
Jay about should computer programmers
what should they do I think for biology
and actual scientific research there is
this element of just getting in the lab
and truly understanding how experiments
are designed and how to interpret them
which I don't I don't know that you can
just learn from not doing but then there
is like a lot of use for for example
bioinformatics and other analysis tools
and platforms where people can get
involved without having lab experience
and we do have some successful companies
and Y Combinator that are founded by non
scientific founders that are in the
biotech space so notable labs is one
that I think is incredibly impressive
the founders have basically self-taught
themself everything about
you know the sector that they're in and
the super smart and hungry and you know
straight away when I interviewed them
was like yeah they know just as much as
you know PhDs who work in the space so
two more questions one is just going
back to science exchange for a minute
looking back of all decisions you've
made
what what's in the early days what was
aside from just starting the start of
itself that's obviously very critical
but what's like a decision you made
where you're looking back you're like
that that was a game-changer that was an
inflection point in my business Wow
there is a good Christian game-changer
actually I think the decision to do the
reproducibility initiative was a
game-changer and it was non obvious so
in some ways the reproducibility
initiative goes against focus it was
kind of a distraction like okay we're
gonna do this project but it's not
directly related to just growing the
marketplace although the marketplace was
used to run the project but it was so
timely and so high-profile that it did
change the branding and the
opportunities for science is change in a
way that we never expected and it did
open all of the doors that eventually
led to our pharmaceutical partnerships
to really like a lot of the 60s of
science exchange so that was probably
one example interesting did not know it
it kind of when I saw it I was like oh
wow science exchange I knew it could be
big but it could be like this much
bigger because it just showed the you
know what you could do with it okay last
question is always my favorite question
in a hundred years from now I mean
you're only you've been around for eight
years at seven eight years now but in a
hundred years from now what do you think
science exchange will be yeah there is a
such an interesting question because I
think if you just think about what the
world will be like in 100 years from now
I'm not sure any of us have a good
answer but you know I do think that a
hundred years ago the scientific method
existed and people were you know doing
scientific research and I said and I
think scientific research will exist 100
years from now
so science is change has always been
extremely purpose driven so you know the
company's purpose is to enable
scientific breakthroughs through
connections and so I think whatever the
world looks like at that time that's you
know what science to change will be
doing and and hopefully we're just
providing that infrastructure that
enables people to instantly work with
whoever they need to collaborate with in
order to make these scientific
breakthroughs happen it's crazy to think
the scientific method was only
discovered invented or do you want to
call it just not long ago and which
creates this explosion of science in
general okay cool well that's all the
questions I have any questions from the
audience back there so the question is
about whether we should look at new
approaches to instead of just looking at
correlations to look for causality
especially in a space with unknown
unknowns so you know I think the way
that so I'm a biologist by training so I
tend to think that you know we're not
just looking at correlations we try to
design experiments that allow us to
change something in the system there is
a controlled system and then read an
output from that and determine whether
that fits of our hypothesis that we
changed something and it has therefore
had this downstream impact I think
there's you know really interesting work
that's been done on correlations
particularly with real-world data so
trying to look for ways that we can
actually use humans in the wild to
examine new theories that we have and
then apply those back into the lab but
it
basically of all when you're in the lab
you are kind of using model systems to
try to reduce the unknown unknowns so
that you can test specific theories so
the question is about going from an idea
to an MVP in a short space of time and
the steps that required to do that and
for us actually there was one of the
lessons that I really took when I
started science exchange was try to do
something really quickly and get it off
the ground because I see a lot of people
start companies and they have a lot of
enthusiasm at the start and then they're
also working like full-time jobs and
trying to do this on the side and the
progress you make obviously is limited
because you just don't have the time to
put into it so we are possible I think
it's it's really great if you can kind
of just take time out to say okay I'm
going to do like Y Combinator or
something for three months and really
launch the company
so for us we literally had the idea and
then it was the I think it was February
2011 and and we kind of we're talking
about different ideas and then we we
thought this is really a good idea and
so then we applied to Y Combinator so we
made this video and it was just me and
my co-founder we had nothing and then
actually Y Combinator Alexis Ohanian he
Skyped me and he said you're not gonna
get in and I was like oh no why it was
slow because you don't have a technical
co-founder and you really need a
technical co-founder and so we then
spoke to all of our friends and we found
a technical co-founder and this was all
just in like two weeks and then we built
actually a really hack to give the
vision of the MVP and we came to our
interview and we had already got
something kind of was very basic but we
had something and and then we got in and
we moved out here in May and it was
three months of just okay now let's get
that launched and we were actually doing
transactions off platform so we actually
were talking with all of our scientists
and I was traveling a lot talking to you
know all of the people who I could get
to use the product so we actually did
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
transactions during that time just to
prove that we understood the demand and
the supply side you know yeah so the
question is about the importance of
credentials in the biotech space and I
think credentials are very important so
if you can have you know credentials in
the space it's just you know it's going
to give you obviously a huge advantage
but in saying that I don't think it's we
have examples where people have been
successful without that and how they
were successful is by being incredibly
credible themselves when you actually
interview them so in the example of
notable labs when I interviewed Matt and
Pete they just had researched everything
about the space like they'd read every
scientific paper they knew in depth
about cancer stem cells about the
limitations about the essays that they
wanted to use and I met with them much
longer than I would have would have if I
had a surrogate which would be the
credential of them having a PhD from a
top university but by talking to them it
was clear that they did understand the
space and that they were incredibly
motivated due to a family connection to
really try to
put something in place that could help
solve this issue which was in the case
of them they were looking for new
therapeutics for glioblastoma and and so
I think if you are not a scientist
having a personal driver of why you're
doing this actually can serve as a
surrogate to get you in the door so it
can get you meetings with top scientists
it can get you meetings with patient
advocacy groups that can help you sort
of get the company started I think it
can I think if you're building a biotech
company you obviously have to build a
scientific team and then you'll end up
with PhDs in your team but you can be a
co-founder without a PhD so the question
is about when did I decide to leave the
university and so I was so fortunate
when I started science exchange and I
think a lot of people don't realize how
difficult and I totally don't take this
for granted like when people ask me
about our journey of studying sizes
change I think we had you know enormous
luck in the sense that my boss was the
Dean of Medicine at the University of
Miami and he was incredibly supportive
of science exchange so he thought it was
a great idea he thought that if you know
if I didn't do it then like somebody
else would do it and so he actually let
me take three months off to go and do
this and he looked after my lab for me
while I was gone and then once we're out
here it was clear that the idea was
going to be successful and we raised
funding straight out of YC and so I
decided I'm not going to go back and I
was actually nervous about telling him I
wasn't going to go back but he was so
amazing about it he was just like yeah
and that was doing great like I knew it
would be a great success and so having
that mentor who gave me the opportunity
I just I think not many people get that
especially in academia like that's
actually again where
sometimes have this frustration of I
hear the opposite of PhD students and
postdocs they tell me oh my my boss just
really didn't want me to leave like
really didn't want me to start a company
actively worked against me
rather than helped me and I think about
my experience and how different it would
have been if I didn't have his support
all right last question Rena yes so the
question is about quality control and a
two sided marketplace so for us quality
control is incredibly important and
actually is one of the core value
propositions of science exchange so we
qualify all suppliers before they're
available through the marketplace and
then we also have a continuous
monitoring process where we actually
look at performance of every single
transaction so we have more data on
performance than anybody else and we can
actually say with certainty well at
least most indeed than other people this
provider will likely do a very good job
on this type of experiment we also put
in place the way our actual platform is
structured it is clear and there clear
outline of the deliverables that are
generated the expectations are set up
front and I think a really interesting
step that we track closely as science
exchanges Net Promoter Score is 78 and
our suppliers net promoter score is 67
and the industry average is zero so we
think that's amazing because it's the
same suppliers but when used through the
platform they perform much better and I
think the reason is because it's
structured and it's clearly outlined
what's going to be delivered and then
there's any expectation that if you
don't perform the information will
actually be available to everyone else
when they're making a decision so it
becomes a very strong and Center for
people to perform and make sure that
they're delivering what they agreed upon
all right thank you so much Elizabeth
you like everyone
[Applause]
you